Wow hello and welcome to this video
playing ml Rocca wow isn't that a GM
that set the Sun yeah you see that blitz
raining here three 6 44 this is pretty
higher this is Nakamura level but yeah
this is a side account of somebody I
guess let's see what happens in the in
the Italian somo had the feeling that
would happen but I don't know yeah that
line it's not particularly great but d5
isn't white supposed to Castle there
check hmm that's kind of curious
okay Queen to e7 Bishop e2 Bishop a one
Queen a one take a one Queen cheeks and
that it's not entirely clear g7 is
hanging I feel that I should be able to
do something here I mean you can just
take and be okay but I feel okay let's
do that it costs a lot of time maybe
queen king e seven here but maybe like
some kinky one is happening ok so I'm
going with this yeah this is this is
something that white can definitely play
it's not nothing special though couldn't
add almost the same thing out of a
different move water I think I had the
same position actually against some
other guy recently ok so i have to
develop my mag bishop somehow he have
two pieces there are two points up
though and in the other in the other
game it was just just one pawn ok so i
get this away it's now probably Bishop
to e6
I have to return one point anyway
doesn't want it ok so I'm going to keep
this and go for development with root
the eight
going for up to seven and route the
aider possible
main danger here is some trickery but
Rupert e7 looks fairly sound and see no
tricks on the back rank or anything like
that okay now let's go 85 here then
rotate next
maybe 94 is a move well okay okay did
not happen maybe it wasn't such a big
deal between c4 to take a for Queen
before is also good if I get that in
yeah that's that's that's a good one he
doesn't want to trade but also doesn't
have a good square okay maybe go for
more centralization here 32 yeah 24
maybe centralizing
so before now that a pawn is the thing
to win check
okay that's actually not helping that's
not helping even though I probably
rather want to keep the bishop here time
morning yeah I am I didn't want to give
up seven but maybe it's not such a big
deal porn is dangerous
yeah I'm not playing this too well how
do I get the a pawn for the advanced
check this mine a 3 a 2
alright it's got f4 f4 f4 f5 96 this
kind of meat/meat tricks
37 seconds
check I got out of this unbelievable and
still nothing happening but I've got 25
seconds and he escaped from that
completely lost pollution no it's just a
draw no whatever I hate this stuff I am
I can take whatever I'm just completed
here signs how can I lose this game this
is really embarrassing to no end after
what the nonsense that he played the
whole game it's two pawns down for
nothing then one point down for nothing
and I managed to screw this up amazing
it's really amazing what I'm doing check
is still still winning probably but yeah
it's unfortunately after Knight f6 it's
a draw it's just a native eight was was
drawing but okay he wants to win on time
I just still can't play Bishop c4 and
win with the a porn but it was so easily
winning before that whole opening line
is just losing for watching it's just
losing well at least clear she was
channel I'm two points up here yeah I'm
kind of kind of nonplussed here yeah it
was okay i mean i wasn't even that slow
it took her took a long time early on
trying to if I can win like immediately
here but didn't didn't see it just two
points then but I should have just gone
for that and have more time more time
even though which the time it's so
pretty easy winning so
yeah don't know what the same I got kind
of frustrated already because I knew it
will be difficult with 40 seconds and
can yeah that would end game yeah it's a
draw but you know you know you lose on
time 27 seconds not much you can do it
shuffles around doing nothing or here
like I whatever um yeah not much to say
it's just one of those games where your
opponent gives you the point on the
silver plate and you don't take it kind
of kind of a shame anyway thanks for
watching